[Music]
Brad Pitt is now Hollywood's most
eligible bachelor but is he already
dating a famous supermodel or Jude Law's
ex because that's what everybody's
talking about gonna be both or maybe
it's neither we're getting to the bottom
of the latest romance rumors they're
looking fuzing but what's clear is
Brad's got his single man mojo back Brad
and Sienna Miller or Brad with the body
elle macpherson these are the two
different ladies Brad is hooking up with
depending on which headline you believe
Brad and Sienna supposedly had a three
a.m. hookup at this weekend's
Glastonbury music festival in England
that is where the single star was also
seen getting photo bombed by Bradley
Cooper and hangin with Tilda Swinton but
Pitt allegedly ended the party kissing
35 year old Sienna in the VIP section
the quote online getting clicks they
couldn't keep their hands off each other
but our source set the story straight
saying Brad is actually friends with si
Ana's boyfriend is Moneyball director
Bennett Miller and then there's al a new
report today claims Brad was spotted
recently in Hollywood on an intimate
date flirting with the supermodel we'd
so love to believe this rumor both stars
are 53 years old and hot both recently
split from the long-term loves and they
both have a link to Jen Aniston since
they reportedly met when L was a guest
star on friends but sorry guys a source
tells us this date never happened Brad
wasn't even in LA on the night this all
supposedly went down
okay so Brad isn't dating either one of
them our source says that people just
want to match him with whomever they see
him with but they shouldn't there's
nothing of note going on he is just
living its life
[Music]
you